welcome to part two of the presentation
on quadratic equations well I think I
thoroughly confuse you the last time
around so let me see if I can fix that a
bit by doing several more examples so
let's just start with a review of what
the quadratic equation is the quadratic
equation says if I'm trying to solve the
equation a x squared plus BX plus C
equals 0 then the solution or the
solutions because there's usually two
times that it intersects the x axis or
two solutions for this equation is x
equals minus b plus or minus the square
root of b squared minus 4 times a times
C and all of that over 2a so let's do a
problem and hopefully this should make a
little more sense that's a 2 on the
bottom so let's say I had the equation
minus 9 x squared minus 9 X plus 6
equals 0 so in this example what's a
well a is the coefficient on the x
squared term the x squared term is here
the coefficient is minus 9 so let's
write that a equals minus 9 what does B
equal B is the coefficient on the X term
so that's this term here so B is also
equal to minus 9 and C is a constant
term which is in this example is 6 so C
is equal to 6 now we just substitute
these values into the actual quadratic
equation so negative B so it's negative
times negative 9 right that's B plus or
minus the square root or B squared so
that's 81 right negative 9 squared minus
4
times negative nine right that's a times
C which is six and all of that over 2
times negative 9 which is minus 18 all
right 2 times negative 2 a 2 times
negative 9 let's try to simplify this up
here well negative negative 9 that's
positive 9 plus or minus the square root
of 81 C 4 this is negative 4 times
negative 9 negative 4 times negative 9
is positive 36 and then positive 36
times 6 is let's see 30 times 6 is 180
and then 180 plus another 36 is 2 16
plus 216 is that right
180 plus 36 right is 216 all of that
over 2a 2a we already said is minus 18
so you simplify that more that's 9 plus
or minus the square root 81 plus 216
that's 80 plus 217 that's 297 297 and
all of that over minus 18 now this is
actually the hardest part with the
quadratic equation is actually
oftentimes just simplifying this
expression we have to figure out if we
can simplify this radical let's see one
way to just figure out if a number is
divisible by 9 is to actually add up the
digits and see if the digits are
divisible 9 then in this case it is 2
plus 9 plus 7 is equal to 18 so let's
see how many times 9 goes into that I'll
do it on the side here I don't want to
be too messy 9 goes into 297 it goes it
goes the 3 3 times 27 27 goes 33 times
right so this is the same thing as 9
plus or minus the square root of 9 times
33 / - 18 and 9 is a perfect square
that's why I actually wanted to see if 9
would work because that's the only way I
could get it out of the radical if it's
a perfect square as you learned that
exponent rules number one module so this
is equal to 9 plus or minus 3 times the
square root of 33 and all of that over -
18 we're almost done we can actually
simplify it because 9 3 and minus 18 are
all divisible by 3
so this is equal to let's divide
everything by 3 3 plus or minus plus or
minus the square root of 33 over minus 6
and we are done so as you see the
hardest thing with the quadratic
equation is often just simplifying the
expression but what we've said I know
you might have lost track on we did all
of this math is we said this equation
minus 9x squared minus 9x plus 6 now we
found two x-values that would satisfy
this equation and make make it equal to
0 one x value is x equals 3 plus the
square root of 33 over minus 6 and the
second value is 3 minus the square root
of 33 over minus 6 and you might want to
think about why + where we have that
plus or minus we'll add that plus or
minus because the square root could
actually be a positive or a negative
number let's do another problem
hopefully this one will be a little bit
a little bit simpler let's say I wanted
to solve minus 8x squared plus 5x plus 9
now I'm going to assume that you've
memorized a quadratic equation because
that's something you should do or you
should write down on a piece of paper
but the quadric issue is negative B so B
is 5 right so it's we're trying to solve
that equals 0 so negative B so negative
5 plus or minus the square
root of b-squared that's 5 squared 25
minus 4 times a which is minus 8 times C
which is 9 and all of that over 2 times
a well a is minus 8 so that's all of
that is over a minus 16 so let's
simplify this expression up here well
that's equal to minus 5 plus or minus
the square root of 25 let's see 4 times
8 is 32 and the negatives cancel out so
that's positive 32 times 9 positive 32
times 9 let's see 30 times 9 is 270 its
288 288 I think right 3232 70 and then
we have it
288 we have all of that over minus 16
now simplify it more minus 5 plus or
minus the square root 25 plus 288 is 313
I believe 313 all of that over minus 16
and I think I'm not 100% sure although
I'm pretty sure I haven't checked it the
313 can't be factored into a product of
a perfect square and another number in
fact it actually might be a prime number
that's something that you might want to
check out so if that is the case and
we've gotten it in completely simplified
form and we say there are two solutions
to X values that will make this equation
true
one of them is X is equal to minus 5
plus the square root of 313 over minus
16 and the other one is X is equal to
minus 5 minus the square root of 313
over minus 60
hopefully those two examples will give
you a good sense of how to use the
quadratic equation I might add some more
modules and then once you master this
I'll actually teach you how to solve
quadratic equations when you actually
get a negative number under the radical
very interesting anyway I hope you can
do the module now and maybe I'll add a
few more presentations because this
isn't the easiest module but I hope you
have fun bye